Okay, so here is the code for the class Movie
that we have written thus far. Now, bear in mind, that
you may have to go into full-screen mode in order
to see all of the details here properly. And I'm really
curious to figure out what happens behind the scenes when
I run this line of code. What happens when I create
an instance called toy_story by providing these four pieces of
information or arguments. These pieces of information are the name of
the movie, its story line, the link to its poster,
and the link to its YouTube URL. Now clearly, the
last two of these are not really links or URLs
just yet. They are English phrases and I did that because
there wasn't enough space on the screen for me to
add the full links or the URLs to the poster and
the YouTube trailer. So, the first thing that happens when
we learn this line of code is that the init function
gets called. And the init function, you
will recall, is the function we defined inside
class Movie. Self, in that case, is itself
or the instance being created, which is toy_story.
The next argument is movie_title whose value
is Toy Story. Movie_storyline gets the value Toys
come to life. The variable poster_image gets the
right value. And finally, the trailer_youtube variable gets
the correct link. Okay, so far so good. Now, once init gets called and
all of these arguments receive their correct
values, all of the variables that are associated
with the instance toy_story, they get initialized
appropriately and these variables, you may notice,
are title, storyline, poster_image_url and trailer_youtube_url. At
this point, if I try to print out
toy_story.storyline, it prints out the correct value. All right,
now that we know exactly what happens when we create
this instance toy story. Let's go back to our
design and find out what we have to do next.